[Musik]
die erste station für jeden der in miami
verhaftet wird
wir warten die insassen auf ihre
gerichtsverhandlung ist niemand sicher
auf ihrer verurteilung oder ihre
freilassung lasst mich raus hier leben
7000 kriminelle auf engstem raum
heute werden abgestochen
unvorhergesehene dinge passieren
und es kann jederzeit zu übergriffen
kommen da ist eine schlägerei
miami im us bundesstaat florida eine
stadt des glamours und der gefahr
in miami sind schlägereien unter
betrunkenen an der tagesordnung und die
mordrate ist doppelt so hoch wie im
durchschnitt der usa
jede nacht macht die polizei razzien in
den straßen der stadt
keine bewegung die verhaftung ist für
alle vom mörder bis zum kleinkriminellen
erster beginn ihrer reise sollen wir sie
noch verhaften aber ich habe nichts
gemacht eine reise die sie auf direktem
weg ins gefängnis wir machen den anfang
wir gehen da raus und schnappen uns die
leute die ins gefängnis gehören so fängt
alles an
jede nacht bringt die polizei die
verdächtigen hierher in eines der
größten und härtesten gefängnisse des
landes das miami date county
untersuchungsgefängnis
als erstes durchläuft jeder neue
häftling die aufnahme prozedur 200
werden es in dieser nacht zahlen mehr
als 70.000 in diesem jahr
damit ist das gefängnis eines der
betriebsam ssten der usa
wir haben immer auf die polizei sorgt
schon dafür wenn die jungs ihren job
machen müssen wir unseren machen wir
müssen die leute irgendwie unterbringen
wir können ja niemanden nach hause
schicken es gibt einen großen
unterschied zwischen strafvollzug und
untersuchungshaft im strafvollzug sitzen
verurteilte verbrecher ein in ein
untersuchungsgefängnis kommen ständig
neue häftlinge über deren schuld oder
unschuld des gerichtet ist und rein muss
die ungewissheit erzeugt eine enorme
anspannung
was mich raus ihr habt nichts gegen mich
in der hand
heute war schon alles erreicht
drogendelikte vorsätzlicher mord
bewaffneter raubüberfall quer durch die
bank
ich will hier raus die haben meine
fingerabdrücke doch schon
jeder neuankömmling durchläuft dieselbe
prozeduren seine fingerabdrücke werden
genommen er wird durchsucht auf
tuberkulose und geschlechtskrankheiten
untersucht und fotografiert
nach links drehen
wie viele gefängnisse in den usa ist
auch der miami county jail überbelegt
jeder neuzugang so laut dienstvorschrift
innerhalb von acht stunden abgefertigt
werden aber weil ständig neue häftlinge
ankommen ist das fast unmöglich
manche häftlinge warten hier zwölf bis
14 stunden das ist ganz normal
ich warte schon den ganzen tag
die männer und frauen die hier
festgehalten werden haben eines
gemeinsam sie
werden eines verbrechens beschuldigt bis
ihr gerichtsverfahren abgeschlossen ist
oder sie kaution stellen ist es
gefängnis ihr zuhause
der aufnahme truck des neuen kleiner
teil des miami county jail
der knast besteht aus zwei großen
bereichen dem haupttrakt und dem
westflügel
die insassen des westflügels leben
entweder in schlafsälen oder in
einzelzellen der haupttrakt besteht aus
überfüllten alten zellen blogs
insgesamt erstreckt sich das gefängnis
über eine fläche so groß wie fast 60
fußballfelder
im strafvollzug wissen die gefangenen
genau wie lange ihre strafe dauert in
der untersuchungshaft ist alles ungewiss
aktuell sitzen in miami date mehr als
7000 häftlinge ein sie erwartet eine
gefängnisstrafe ein todesurteil oder ein
freispruch manche sind nur für eine
nacht hier andere für zehn jahre
der 27 jährige william nil wurde wegen
diebstahls verhaftet
unter hin schauen sie auf die gelben
punkte
vor treten beide streiten nun wird ihm
seine situation bewusst
ich rufe eine freundin einen gegner
kaution so lange muss ich warten ich
hasse maria
william nil wird in eine sammelstelle
gebracht wo jeder egal ob mörder oder
ladendieb auf seine abfertigung wartet
es gibt keine betten kein essen und
keine ruhe
die wärterinnen und wörter können bei so
viel betrieb nicht überall gleichzeitig
sein
heute nacht ist des alten westens
aufgabe den überwachungskameras zu
beobachten
hier kann jede kleinigkeit zum streit
führen
wir halten immer die augen an man sieht
sofort wenn irgendwo was nicht stimmt
draußen und auch in den zellen
gerade gibt es eine prügelei
schlägerei bei den frauen
heute gibt es ärger in der samenzelle
der frauen es beginnt mit beschimpfungen
und artet in einer prügelei aus
wer hat hier ein problem
ich weiß nicht
ich will nicht zu den in die zelle im
gefängnis wird nicht geheult
diesmal gibt es keine ernsthaften
verletzungen schlägereien gehören hier
zum alltag sie sind so normal dass sie
niemandem erzählt
diese leute sind wegen schwerer vergehen
hier sie hören nicht auf verbrechen zu
begehen nur weil sie im gefängnis sind
manchmal geht die ganze zelle hoch
die letzte rettung vor einer nacht im
gefängnis ist ein anruf die einzige
chance um die kaution aufzutreiben
ich hoffe eine freundin an hoffentlich
geht's
juli hofft auf seine beste freundin
er hat nur drei minuten zeit wie jeder
hier
sie können ihr einen kautionsantrag
eine liste mit burgen ich gebe dir einen
namen okay
welcher ist am nächsten wir dürfen dazu
nichts sagen hast du eine schrift
er hat gesagt gerade aus das ist
kompliziert meine herren sie haben noch
eine minute das war's wo sind wir hier
steht davor
dreizehnter straße date county jail gut
das war's jetzt
es ist frustrierend
man soll jemanden wichtige informationen
geben die man selber nicht hat das ist
doch mist
für neil ist die zeit abgelaufen er wird
die nacht im gefängnis verbringen morgen
wird seine freundin die kaution stellen
und er wird wieder auf freiem fuß seien
aber für die meisten ist der weg durch
diese tür erst der anfang sie werden
tiefer in die mühlen der justiz geraten
und vom untersuchungshäftling zum
strafgefangenen werden
miami hat eine der höchsten raten an
gewaltverbrechen in den gesamten usa
und das gefängnis ist hier keine
ausnahme
mehr als 7000 häftlinge sitzen aktuell
ma identität von college-studenten mit
gefälschten ausweisen bis hin zu mördern
die auf der flucht gefasst worden ihnen
allen werden vergehen zur last gelegt
aber sie sind noch nicht verurteilt
in der anstalt gibt es zwei sehr
unterschiedliche arten der haft
zum einen altmodische dunkle und enge
zellen mit stahlgittern
zum andern ein hochmoderner offener
schlafsaal in dem die insassen 24
stunden am tag beaufsichtigt werden
in welchem teil man landet hält oft
schlicht davon ab wo gerade ein bett
frei ist
doch die herausforderung ist die selbe
die kontrolle zu behalten
officer vincent regatta ist noch neu in
dieser welt hinter gittern
den schlüssel bitte
es ist seine erste woche
er beginnt seine schicht im haupttrakt
mit einem rundgang
[Applaus]
warten sie auf
die insassen versuchen ständig dich
nieder zu sterben sie beobachten jede
deiner bewegungen sie wollen sehen ob du
stark oder schwach bist
[Musik]
da macht mindestens sechsmal pro schicht
einen rundgang im älteren praxis
gefängnisses gibt es keine kameras in
den zellen und keine hightech tieren
hier müssen sich die wörter persönlichen
respekt erarbeiten
[Musik]
merken wenn du ein anfänger bist sie
können es beinahe riesen seine uniform
ist zaubert ein hemd ist noch ganz weiß
sie sehen die blitzblank polierte schuhe
die hart wie du gehst deine anspannung
bitte nehmen sie die daraus
in der ausbildung habe ich gelernt
selbstvertrauen zu zeigen ihnen in die
augen zu schauen und nun den blick
abzuwenden
man tut halt so als ob man sich stark
fühlt
wessen unterwäsche ist das nehmen sie
die runter
tief drinnen haben wir alle angst aber
wir lassen dieses gefühl draußen vor der
tür denn wenn die gefangenen die angst
riechen dann nutzen sie das aus
im gefängnis darf niemand schwäche
zeigen weder die aufseher noch die
insassen
indem sie ihre tasche der häftling david
videos musste diese lektion früh lernen
ich muss für mich selbst einstehen und
kämpfen wenn man sich einmal respektlos
behandeln lässt passiert das immer
wieder
dem mittel medius ist seit er 15 jahre
alt war immer wieder im gefängnis dieses
mal ist er wegen mehrerer fälle von
einbruch und schweren diebstahl
angeklagt
gewalt ist für ihn das einzige mittel um
die zeit im knast zu überstehen
heute wird er nach 15 tagen in
einzelhaft wegen einer schlägerei zurück
in eine normale zelle verlegt
wenn man in eine zelle kommt ist man
immer nervös denn man weiß nicht was
einen erwartet man muss total aufpassen
dass man jeden in der zelle kennt man
weiß nie was sie tun werden das sind
schließlich alles kriminelle
auf der straße oder hier drin das sind
ihre
bei jeder verlegung in eine andere zelle
geht es für medius von vorn los er muss
mögliche gefahren erkennen und sich
notfalls respekt verschaffen
ich darf nicht zulassen dass mich alle
schlecht sonst nimmt das kein ende mehr
wenn man sich hier was gefallen lässt
wird man fertig gemacht
du machst irgendwas mit einem passt das
nicht du sagst fast falsches oder guckst
mich einfach nur scharf an ich bin
einfach nur schlecht drauf und schon
gehts
schlägereien wie diese in einem anderen
gefängnis schaukeln sich hoch und sind
irgendwann nicht mehr zu stoppen man
kann nur die problematischen gefangenen
auseinanderhalten
das ist ein minus 15 t zelle im
haupttrakt jedes mal wurde wegen einer
schlägerei verlegt und jedes mal muss er
sich bei neuen zellengenossen behaupten
als er in die zelle km haben alle
begrüßt doch heute abend könnte schon
wieder ärger geben die prügeln sich
wegen allem gegen essen dem
fernsehprogramm egal was
im gefängnis ändern sich die
machtverhältnisse ständig
es ist schwer friedlich zu bleiben denn
manche leute wollen dich testen wollen
wissen wie weit sie bei dir gehen können
müsste ich nirgends ein und halt
möglichst die klappe sonst bekommt so
schnell ärger
im haupttrakt sitzen 24 männer in einer
zelle der raum ist kaum größer als ein
schulbus
das hier ist jetzt unser zuhause
hier werden leute abgestochen es gibt
kaum regeln keine zugeteilten britschen
und keinen verantwortlichen
du suchst dir ein der unter der schläft
im knast ihm einer der gewinner bekommt
dann das untere bett um jede kleinigkeit
wird gekämpft um essen genauso wie um
das fernsehprogramm
ich schaue gerne boxkämpfe die wollten
seifenopern sehen er hat zugeschlagen
ich habe zurückgeschlagen dabei hat er
meinen daumen fast abgerissen den haben
sie abgeschnitten ich sollte auf den
finger hier verlieren aber den haben sie
daran gelassen aber drei sind weg
die aufseher wissen dass es jeden tag
schlägereien gibt meistens wenn sie
gerade nicht hinsehen die gefangenen
regeln ihren streit am liebsten unter
sich in einem kleinen bereich der zelle
der die zone genannt wird wenn sie es
die zone hier geht man hin um zu kämpfen
vor ein paar tagen war hier alles voller
blut wie muss man das auf vision ich
habe immer noch blut an meinem schoß
sobald du durch diese tür gehst können
die aufseher die ihr nicht mehr helfen
du kannst nur noch an das fenster
klopfen und hoffen dass sie kommen
so nett mir helft mir wenn jemand kommt
hast du pech gehabt
die aufseher können die gewalt nicht
verhindern aber sie können versuchen zu
verhindern dass dabei jemand ums leben
kommt deshalb werden die zellen
regelmäßig komplett durchsucht ohne
ankündigung
heute ist officer resultat das erste mal
dabei alles liegenlassen und rauskommen
als erstes werden die gefangenen aus
ihren zellen geholt
los los alle taschen auf die deutschen
legen in
diesem job hängt dein leben davon ab
dass du immer aufmerksam bist du musst
immer bei der sache sein
jeder insasse wird durchsucht um die
zellen werden regelrecht auf den kopf
gestellt
es ist ein katz und maus spiel hier
gegen sie
ich war es nicht was das hier ist aber
da ist definitiv aus
marihuana
anders aus im strafvollzug kommen hier
jeden tag neue gefangene ran das macht
es schwer drogen und waffen draußen zu
halten jesus 678 pillen drei erfahrene
insassen können sich außerdem fast alles
selbst basteln was sie brauchen das
waren dem loch dort oben
es ist eine art wein sie nehmen ein
stück brot etwas zucker oder obst und
wasser das ganze lassen sie ein paar
tage fermentieren und dann betreten sie
sich damit
diese tüte gefangen er ist zentren
sie mischen ihn mit wasser und bauen
eine doppelte wand hinter der sie waffen
oder drogen versteckt
die jungs im kreativ hier haben sie die
farbe abgezogen sie ziehen sie
abschneiden sie zu unüberlegten damit
ihre verstecke vor allem suchen die
aufseher nach sogenannten schenks
improvisierte aber tödliche waffen
trotz regelmäßiger durchsuchungen werden
immer wieder schenks gefunden
das sind ganz normale rasierer sie
brechen sie ab und schneiden damit
leuten streifen fast alles von einer
zahnbürste bis zu einem kugelschreiber
oder einem tablett kann zu einer waffe
werden
es ist extrem wichtig für uns diese
waffen zu finden denn sie können nicht
gegen andere insassen sondern auch gegen
aufseher verbindet
heute haben die aufseher glück sie
finden eine klinge unter der matratze
eines gefangenen
geschenk
eine waffe zu finden ist eine sache raus
zu kriegen wir sie gemacht hat und wofür
ist eine andere
in miami county jail warten die
gefangenen wochen monate manchmal jahre
auf ihr urteil
bis dahin ist das gefängnis ihr zuhause
der haupttrakt wurde in den 50er jahren
gebaut viele finden das gebäude mit
seinen dunklen gängen und stahlgittern
überholt und schwer zu kontrollieren
in den 90er jahren wurde das gefängnis
erweitert seitdem gibt es einen neuen
modernen trakt für gefangene mit hoher
mittlerer und niedriger sicherheitsstufe
mental west liegt 25 kilometer vom
haupttrakt entfernt
die gesamte einrichtung wird von diesem
kontrollraum aus überwacht
das gehirn der einrichtung es ist wie
ein flughafen tower ich kontrolliere
alle türen und alle kameras des gesamten
gebäudes
metro west beherbergt etwa 3000 insassen
sie leben in schlafsälen von bis zu 84
personen
wenn es probleme gibt kann der bereich
vom kontrollraum aus abgeriegelt werden
wenn wir etwas übersehen wird es schnell
lebensgefährlich wenn mal eine tür offen
gelassen wird und ein gefangener calw
läden haben wir ein problem
aber letztlich kommt es auf den direkten
kontakt mit den häftlingen an und
nirgends ist dieser kontakt enger als
hier
mehr auf zu telefonieren es gibt gleich
essen schnell duschen und raus hier
anders als im haupttrakt wo die auf sehr
selten einen zelle betreten sind sie
hier metro west mit den gefangenen in
einem raum eingeschlossen 24 stunden am
tag
nehmen sie das von der wand das geht
nicht
man muss ihnen klar machen was die
regeln sind sie werden trotzdem die
grenzen testen mal sehen wie weit wir
gehen können als aufseher muss ich mehr
respekt verschaffen
lolita menschen arbeitet seit 15 jahren
hier sie ist immer in unterzahl in jeder
schicht müssen zwei aufseher 84
häftlinge bewachen
man muss mit 84 verschiedenen
persönlichkeiten zurechtkommen
betten check wie betten check stellen
sie auch
als frau bist du entweder die freundin
oder die mami das erste was ich ihnen
sage ist ich bin nicht eure mama ich bin
nicht eure freundin für euch bin ich
officer messen
ihre intuition ist in dieser umgebung
auf lisa nelsons bester schutz sie muss
voraus ahnen was als nächstes passiert
wenn man die insassen beobachtet merkt
man wenn ein aufstand oder eine
schlägerei bevorsteht wenn sich einer
seltsam benimmt oder so dann spricht man
mit ihnen und wenn einer nichts sagen
will auch gut man behält die sache im
auge und macht halt seinen job
bei ihrer aufgabe bekommen die aufseher
hilfe von unerwarteten verbündeten von
bestimmten häftlingen sie nennen sich
selbst zählen sprecher und sind
langjährige meist ältere gefangene die
sich gut geführt haben wir sind kein
aufseher aber die aufseher geben uns
viel verantwortung sie erhalten ordnung
in der zelle denn sonst würde hier das
chaos regieren
sie behalten die zelle im auge und
sorgen dafür dass alles glatt läuft es
geht um kontrolle sie helfen uns dabei
michael harris ein ehemaliger us marin
sitzt von allen am längsten in celle 24
er ist der sprecher jeder neuankömmling
muss sich zuerst bei ihnen vorstellen
heute heißt der neuling alberto kind her
er musste bereits fünf mal wegen
schlägereien die zellen wechseln jetzt
soll michael harris ihn auf kurs bringen
ich passe auf sie auf die bauen sonst
sofort wieder misst
man muss sich zusammenreißen du kannst
nicht in die zelle kommen und strahlt
suchen dann fliegst du gleich wieder
raus wir haben keine zeit für so was das
ist chaos das brauchen wir nicht
auch michael harris kämpft gegen die
raue wirklichkeit im knast hier
überleben nur die härtesten in einem
gefängnis egal ob modern oder altmodisch
kann die gewalt uhr plötzlich
explodieren
diese aufnahmen stammen aus einem
anderen gefängnis und zeigen wie schnell
aus einer schlägerei ein aufstand werden
kann
trotz modernster sicherheitskonzepte so
viele häftlinge auf engstem raum bleiben
ein risiko
[Applaus]
oder du bist fertig gemacht daran führt
kein weg vorbei entweder du kämpfst und
stehst für dich ein oder du gehst und
[Musik]
ich versuche ihn etwas klar zu machen
sie halten es für ein spiel aber es ist
kein spiel hier drin spielst du mit
deinem leben
michael harris weiß wovon er spricht
ich werfe von hier
der ehemalige us marine wurde wegen
eines drogendeliktes aus dem dienst
entlassen seitdem war immer wieder in
untersuchungshaft
dieses mal geht es um den besitz von
kokain
harris wurde jedoch nie zu einer
gefängnisstrafe verurteilt
[Musik]
ihn können wir vertrauen auf ihn hören
wir wenn's zu krass wird
ich respektiere die jungs also werde ich
auch von ihnen respektiert
doch respekt ist nicht alles was michael
harris will er will raus und seine
chance könnte zum greifen nah sein
[Musik]
in miami date kam dj warten über 7000
häftlinge auf ihre verfahren auf einer
verurteilung oder ihre entlassung doch
selbst im gefängnis nimmt die
kriminalität kein ende
im haupttrakt werden bei einer
durchsuchung verbotene gegenstände und
waffen gefunden
es macht mir große sorgen wenn wir so
etwas finden denn es heißt dass meine
aufseher in gefahr sind
hier hat er die klinge geschärft
man sieht die schleifspuren am boden so
geht das
wir haben die waffe dort an der wand
gefunden die anderen müssen ihm
vertrauen wenn sie ihnen erlauben direkt
vor ihrer nase ein messer zu wetzen die
waffe zu finden ist nur der erste
schritt jetzt müssen die aufseher
herauskriegen wem sie gehört
ich weiß nicht wer hier schläft die
briten sind nicht so geteilt man weiß
nicht genau wo schläft
wir gehen darüber zu der anhörung mal
sehen was das komitee dazu zu sagen hat
aber
an der tasche können wir sehen wer es
ist
die tasche führt die aufseher zu diesem
häftling christopher jackson sofort wird
er zu einer disziplin anhörung gebracht
man hat eine waffe unter ihrer matratze
gefunden was sagen sie dazu ich bin
unschuldig nicht schuldig also was war
los man hatte mir untergeschoben
jackson behauptet dass die waffe von
jemandem unter seiner pritsche deponiert
wurde nun muss er einen namen nennen
oder er wird in einzelhaft verlegt
sie will ihn dort deponiert haben
für jackson ist es sicherer den schweine
kodex häftlinge zu befolgen wer als
verräter gilt muss im gefängnis um sein
leben fürchten
mögen keine verräter
du darfst dir keine pässe sein
irgendwer hat ihn da hingelegt er gehört
mir nicht
sein schweigen könnte jackson einzelhaft
oder einer verlegung in den
hochsicherheitstrakt einbringen
der hochsicherheitstrakt liegt innerhalb
von metro west in diesen knast im knast
werden die gewalttätigsten häftlinge
weggesperrt diese männer stellen das
größte risiko für aufseher und andere
gefangene dar diese jungs sind hier weil
sie wichtige gefangenen sind gewiefte
ausbrecher oder einfach wirklich
schlimme typen das sind die sorgenkinder
unsere einrichtung
[Musik]
der hochsicherheitstrakt liegt im ersten
stock des metro west gebäudes im moment
sind hier einen 50 gefangene in sechs
quadratmeter großen einzelzellen
untergebracht
es gibt so gut wie keinen menschlichen
kontakt die insassen sind 24 stunden am
tag 7 tage die woche eingeschlossen
so wie sich eine schuhschachtel man kann
hier nichts tun als grübel wird verrückt
hier drin
in celle 127 sitzt angefangen hat der
diese wende genau kennt tavares kenne
way ist seit über zehn jahren hier in
einzelhaft
die einsamkeit ist hat man hat nur diese
vier wände viele wünschen sich stille
doch in der isolationshaft muss man sich
mit der stille anfreunden oder sie kann
sehr laut werden
tavares calloway wird wohl nie aus
seiner isolationshaft entlassen werden
wenn er es wegen grausamer verbrechen
angeklagt
1997 soll calloway fünf männer gefesselt
geknebelt und regelrecht hingerichtet
haben der fall machte damals
schlagzeilen heute sitzt er noch immer
in untersuchungshaft während der fall
vor gericht verhandelt wird das ist
nicht ungewöhnlich bei derart
aufsehenerregenden fällen besonders wenn
das urteilen die todesstrafe bedeuten
könnte
der todestag ist natürlich am
schlimmsten aber für mich macht das
keinen unterschied todestag oder
gefängnis eingesperrt ist man überall
nur im todestrakt blasen sie die am ende
die lichter aus
in wenigen tagen hatte wahres calloway
einen gerichtstermin bei dem sich nun
endlich sein schicksal offenbaren könnte
für gefangene die schwere verbrechen
begangen haben ist die untersuchungshaft
der beginn einer langen strafe der 23
jährige daniel london steht am anfang
seiner reise hinter gitter er soll vier
mal auf eine frau geschossen haben
zweimal davon ins gesicht und muss sich
deshalb wegen versuchten mordes
verantworten
sobald er durch diese tür kunst erkennst
du schon am geruch des dem date county
jail
behalten sie unterhose und socken hang
alles andere kommt die tüte
hier drin wollte ich die wirklichkeit
ein
im juli 2008 feierte denn in london mit
freunden in einem hotel in miami
am frühen morgen soll rondon angeblich
vier mal aus nächster nähe auf seine
opfer geschossen haben nach dreitägiger
flucht und einer stadtweiten verhandlung
stellte er sich der polizei
ich wünschte ich könnte die zeit
zurückdrehen und es ungeschehen
aber das geht nicht
ich bekomme fünf bis zehn jahre oder
mehr ich weiß nicht was ich machen soll
werden
trotz der schwere seines verbrechens
könnte daniel rendón kaution stellen er
könnte frei kommen nach tagen oder nach
jahren wie alle untersuchungshäftlinge
weiß er nicht wie lange er hinter
gittern bleiben wird und das ist das
schlimmste
19 jahre ich weiß nicht was ich kriege
lebenslänglich
bis zum ende des prozesses sitzen die
häftlinge erstmal hier fest sei es für
einen tag oder 14 jahre
wenn man nach der aufnahme nicht auf
kaution freikommt ist man nur noch eine
nummer er kann nur noch warten
wenn du kein geld für die kaution hast
musst du hierbleiben du kannst dir 23
jahre sitzen einfach nur warten im
strafvollzug weiß man wenigstens war man
rauskommt
es ist schrecklich hier drinnen
wartet und wartet und wartet
das warten sitzt michael harris zu
es ist fünf uhr morgens und er bereitet
sich auf einen tag bei gericht vor es
ist seine chance frei zu kommen
es ist wie ein schulausflug entweder man
geht nach hause oder man kommt hierher
zurück
man darf sich nicht zu viele hoffnungen
machen man muss cool bleiben
wenn man damit nicht recht nicht raus zu
kommen und dann nie mehr zurück muss ist
enttäuscht
[Musik]
ich muss hier raus
im untersuchungsgefängnis von miami ist
veränderung die einzige konstante mehr
als 7000 insassen müssen zum gericht
gebracht werden in den strafvollzug
verschoben frei gelassen aufgenommen
oder in eine andere zelle verlegt werden
der knast kommt nie zur ruhe
[Musik]
tausende gefangene durchlaufen dieses
system sie müssen montag bis freitag zum
gericht gebracht werden dazu die
aufnahme medizinische versorgung und
notrufe
es ist ein ständiger verkehr
es ist immer viel los und es kann sehr
hektisch werden
die dafür nötige logistik ist eine
herausforderung jeder häftling muss
ständig im auge behalten werden und die
sicherheit garantiert sein
es ist immer ein risiko gefangenen zum
gericht und zurück zu befördern
besonders wenn es sich um einen
bekannten insassen wie tavares calloway
handelt der fünf männer ermordet haben
soll
meine herren das hier ist keine routine
nummer der mann ist gefährlich passen
sie auf
kleine welle muss halt mehr als zehn
jahren immer wieder vor gericht in der
hoch
doch heute könnte eine entscheidung
fallen ränder an die seite nach zehn
jahren untersuchungshaft erwartet ihn
nun lebenslänglich oder die todesstrafe
zwei aufseher und sargent begleiten
sagt der zentrale bescheid
zentrale wir haben stufe 1 auf der
südseite
die erhöhte sicherheitsstufe ist der
schwere seiner verbrechen angepasst
ziehen sie den kopf verein
ein gefangener vita wahres calloway hat
nichts zu verlieren der transport ist
für ihn eine günstige gelegenheit zu
entkommen
[Musik]
ausbrüche sind nicht nur eine abstrakte
gefahr sie sind
dem vergewaltiger reynaldo apano gelang
es das system zu überlisten
im dezember 2005 entkam rapallo über das
dach er seilte sich mit
zusammengebundenen bett lagen ab
weniger als einen monat später klettert
der häftling rodney buckles über einen
stacheldrahtzaun und flieht am
hellichten tag
als andere gefangene zum gericht
gebracht werden nutzt er seine chance
die ausbrüche erschüttern das
untersuchungsgefängnis von miami bis auf
die grundmauern wegen der vorfälle
werden vier aufseher entlassen
schließlich tritt auch der
gefängnisdirektor zurück
der häftling michael harris dem der
besitz von kokain zu last gelegt wird
kämpft vor gericht um seine freiheit
aber acht stunden später ist er wieder
im metro ist
ich hatte gehofft ich könnte raus leider
nicht weiter
michael harris war nummer 19 auf einer
liste von hunderten gefangenen die heute
vor gericht erscheinen mussten wie die
meisten von ihnen hat er den richtern
nicht einmal gesehen denn die gerichte
sind genau so überfüllt wie die
gefängnisse
erst wartest du auf den gerichtstermin
kommst du zum gericht und wartet darauf
den richter zu sehen wenn du ihn
überhaupt siehst du kommst von einer
zelle in die nächste und sag's dir
verdammt ich dachte ich habe ein
gerichtstermin
sie haben in drei monaten ein
gerichtstermin was du hast schon vier
monate gewartet und dann musst du noch
mal drei monate warten man muss einfach
geduldig sein
die häftlinge kommen und gehen die
stimmung schwankt zwischen hoffnung und
enttäuschung und das system muss mit
ihnen fertig werden denn während die
gefangenen warten
müssen die aufseher für die sicherheit
garantieren
durchzählen aufstehen da hinten
jeden tag werden die über 7000 insassen
des mmi date county jail mindestens drei
mal durchgezählt das wichtigste ist dass
alle insassen immer genau da sind wo sie
hingehören
die gefangenen werden so regelmäßig
daran erinnert dass das system die
absolute kontrolle über ihr leben hat
und den aufsehern wird bewusst dass sie
für ordnung zu sorgen haben und dem
gericht das urteil überlassen müssen
ich darf nicht über sie urteilen denn
ich war nicht dabei
du sagst du hast es nicht getan erzählt
es den richtern
ich urteile nicht ein jahr zwei drei
monate und sie sind weg der nächste
bitte
der gefangene tavares calloway soll fünf
männer erschossen haben
er kehrt von einem weiteren
ergebnislosen park vor gericht zurück
[Musik]
nach zehn jahren in untersuchungshaft
ist sein fall immer noch nicht
abgeschlossen
derzeit werden neue beweise geprüft
calloway wartet weiter auf sein urteil
genauso wie die angehörigen seiner opfer
verkehrt in seiner einzelzelle zurück wo
er viel zeit hat über seine
vergangenheit und seine zukunft
nachzudenken
ich verstehe den schmerz der opfer
familie
[Musik]
später wurde calloway schuldig
gesprochen und zum tode verurteilt
das ist ein starkes wort
wie man es auch betrachtet ich musste
diesen weg wählen
für andere nimmt die reise eine
überraschende wende der 23 jährige
daniel london hat eine kaution
hinterlegt sein verfahren steht ihm
bevor er soll vier mal auf eine frau
geschossen haben doch er kann erst mal
nach hause gehen aber über seinem leben
in freiheit liegt ein schatten denn er
weiß dass ihm lebenslange haft droht
ich fühle mich eingesperrt in meinen
eigenen vier wänden psychisch und
physisch das ist das letzte mal dass ich
mir so ein steak braten werde
jeder tag bringt mich dem verlust meiner
freiheit das wird mir mehr und mehr
bewusst das tut weh zu wissen was ich
alles nicht mehr machen kann wenn ich
wieder im knast
alle möglichen gedanken gehen mir durch
den kopf manche sagen soll ab hornig
soll dies und das tun es ist ein
ständiger kampf darum das richtige zu
tun oder eben genau das gegenteil
jetzt ist der nil sondern frei doch die
ungewissheit bleibt
gut hofgang alle raus hier
eine reihen der mitte los
raus aus den federn haus hier ich will
euch laufen sehen
während die insassen ihr schicksal
erwarten geht die routine im gefängnis
weiter
aus den in einer reihe aufstellen
durchsuchungen wie diese dienen der
sicherheit nur so können die wärter
verbotene gegenstände wie waffen drogen
oder alkohol konfiszieren
sie gehen durch unsere ganzen sachen
nehmen die weg sachen die uns gehören
sie bringen unsere post durcheinander
und werfen sie einfach weg
wir können jede woche eine durchsuchung
machen sie finden immer was wenn man
glaubt man hat schon alles gesehen fällt
den wieder was neues ein
in der aufnahme beginnt eine weitere
lange nacht mit hunderten von lingen
es kommen dauernd neue gefangene an es
ist alles dabei von kleinkriminellen bis
zu kapitalverbrechen
wir nehmen jeden manche werden in ein
paar stunden wieder draußen sein andere
jahre lang bleiben im knast kann alles
passieren